what do you tell them about building
their own net worth
and how to go forward and not tripping
up in that aspect so many kids
come out of college 80 000 in debt and
they go
straight downward from there what advice
do you give young kids in terms of
starting their careers and taking care
of themselves financially
i was that kid i came out of school in
1989 with six figures plus in debt
between tufts and harvard
my parents didn't have the money to pay
for so i had to pay for it
and here's what i would tell kids
[Music]
i have a fantastic guest with me today
on
ask mr wonderful good friend of mine
we've met each other through
different sources and definitely
television anthony scaramucci what an
interesting i guess career this guy's
had and i want to talk to him about it
we can all learn
something from it but you know there's
a lot of topics and only little time so
i'm going to try and guide our
discussion through things we can
collectively learn
you know i got to start with the white
house because we are going through an
extraordinary week we're on the cusp of
an administrative change
you're a very interesting guy in this
can i call you tony for the sake of this
interview
well i go i usually go by anthony or
mooch but i'm i'm in
i just i'm in so much what i would
rather call
you is mooch i know you as much i'm
calling you tony
i'm having a very good day i've already
had one bottle of cristal
so i was getting ready for this podcast
i thought that was the right
nurturing thing to do and so yeah you
call me anyone kev i think you know
i love calling you mr wonderful but i'll
tell you who loves
calling you mr wonderful more than
anybody or my sons
who they couldn't believe that i knew
you
and so that was one of those father-son
moments where i was all
putting on my muscles you know my
name-dropping muscles to say hey
not only do i know mr wonderful we're
going to have dinner with you yeah it
was great
it was great and you have a restaurant
your partnership in that i just
love and i hang out there all the time
in those good old days
now mooch let's go back to why you're
having a good day you actually
started your political journey in the
white house
you're an advocate for president trump
you worked for him
you had a very interesting journey in
there you were incredibly good in your
job i thought because
you have a great tv persona and you are
part of communicating trump's message
let's start there how did you because
we're talking about people that want to
learn about
creating careers for themselves how did
you get into the white house how the
hell did that happen
okay so i if it's okay and first of all
thank you it's a huge honor to be on
this so thank you so much but i wanna i
want to go back a little because i think
this will help younger people that
love you and probably watch a lot of the
things that you do
i i want to just set the scene for it's
1989 i'm 25 years old i'm graduating
from harvard law school
and my parents thought it was hartford
law school okay they had no clue right
just give us a blue collar family right
and so i have no network kevin i have no
ability to
meet anybody i'm at goldman i got to
build a network because i'm in the
financial services high net worth space
they give you a desk and a telephone go
build a network and bring in accounts
well i didn't know what to do and so i
started political fundraising and i
wrote my first
check for rudolph giuliani in 1989 for
250
and so you're looking at i'm gonna now
fast forward 31 years
you're looking at the garden variety
republican
fundraiser from new york that happened
to have two successful hedge fund
management businesses that's all i am
and then
accidentally mr trump i'm going to call
him that for a second because he was a
candidate then
wins the election four years ago i was
one of his fundraisers
he found me effective on television so
he would put me on
perpetually and then during the
transition he made me
one of the key transition spokespeople
they put me on and then he came to me
and said i want you to come work for me
now i said no i was hosting wall street
week which you would have been an
amazing guest on
for the fox business channel i said i
like my career i like my job i built my
business i don't feel like selling my
business
he said oh no i'm the president united
states you're going to come work for me
and i got tantalized i got tempted and
so
first learning lesson for young kids
keep your ego in check keep your pride
in check because when you put your pride
and ego into your decision making your
intelligence is going down
on the stock chart and your emotions are
going up and you start making
really disastrous decisions so my wife
who you've met
probably dislikes donald trump almost as
much as melania trump dislikes him i
mean almost i mean you don't have she's
up here and
he's there but it's close okay you got
to give melania the top billing but
she's up there and she said don't do it
it'll be very bad for you
you guys are going to end up being oil
and water you're both bosses don't do it
but i got intoxicated kevin here i am a
blue collar kid from long island
i made some measure of success on wall
street now i'm going to have a chance to
work for the president united states
and so reince priebus and a guy named
steve bannon blocked that job that was
supposed to be his opl director
which is basically his chief networking
officer so i called
president trump i said hey these guys
don't want me to come down there that's
fine i think they're bad guys
if you want to ever get rid of those two
guys call me up i'll come down and fix
it for you
and i and i i went back to my job he
calls me
and he says you're right about these
guys come down i want to talk to you and
then this is where i make colossal
mistake number four billion you know
like h
r block you know the different lessons i
make colossal mistake four billion
i say yes and i take a job that i am
not qualified for i take a job
that a comms director who knows the
beltway
should be in but i'm decent on tv you
know i'm not
hopefully not praising myself mr trump
the least thinks that
he said you can be my comms director
you'll help me clean up the white house
let's get going
mooch are you telling young people not
to jump at opportunity i mean is that
the message
i'm telling people to jump at
opportunity
that are good for them i'm telling them
you know don't take the cool job or
don't take the ego based job take the
job you think you're going to be really
good at and take the job that you think
you're not going to work
you know you love your job okay the
reason why you're forever young
and god willing 30 years from now you'll
invite me back on this podcast when this
is episode 2 million
and you will still be mr wonderful
forever young why because you're doing
something that you love
that short tank station so the lesson is
take the opportunity to think you can
excel at it and you love it and you're
passionate about it yes because then
you're not working but now i'm in the
white house i'm like a fish out of water
these are very different people from us
kevin
i told all my wall street buddies i want
you to imagine the worst person you ever
met on wall street you got that person
in your head
that's the eagle scout in washington
that's the best person that's like the
vicar
of morality in washington and so now i'm
there and those guys are trying to kill
me and i'm trying to kill them
and then i make this colossal mistake
i'm on the phone with a reporter who i
thought was my friend
and i'm a little jocular and i say
something ridiculously off
color about steve bannon you know i was
talking about maybe something that he
probably can't do unless he's really
into flexibility in hot
yoga i'll let your podcast people look
it up what i said he was doing in his
own office
and i said really you're going to write
that about me i said you're going to get
me fired
and the guy said yeah i'm going to write
it i said why are you being so
transactional so learning lesson number
two
don't be transactional build long-term
relationships well i think
mooch you're really saying don't talk to
a reporter and think that it's all off
the record
they're going to take advantage of a con
of a comment you made
person even if you think the person is
your friend their skull scorpion
and they're gonna bite you for that
story and i made that mistake
and by the way that is a rookie mistake
okay that i should have never made that
mistake but here was a guy
whose family had a 50-year relationship
with my family
our parents had known each other for
since 1967
and i trusted him and that was a mistake
you know and he totally screwed you over
he basically ran with it
he had the right to do that because i
didn't say to him this is off the record
kevin
you follow what i'm saying i i so you're
you're not you're not putting all the
blame on him you didn't say it was off
the record you didn't think about it
learning the lesson number three four or
five whatever it is be accountable
i made a mistake i did something
fireball
i got fired it's my fault i didn't do
what the scarecrow did in the wizard of
oz
i'm not blaming anybody else i'm not
saying it was this guy's fault that
guy's well
not my fault what happened to you you
know what i said something stupid
it was fireball for a job like that and
two days later i got fired
and i walked out of there and i said
okay fine
nothing personal i'm gonna still support
president trump i'm gonna try to help
out the
republican agenda but it became
impossible kevin the guy
is nuts he's nuts okay so let's talk
about
there's fantastic lessons here for
people that are pursuing careers i love
the fact that you're willing to be
accountable for your mistakes i totally
agree with that you got to be
transparent you got to take the hit you
got to learn from it
now you leave the white house and this
is where you know i start running into
you on television we're
we're doing all kinds of stuff together
here and there you are amazing on tv and
that's
you're not going to lose that talent
that's the way it is i'm not a shark
look at you i mean the other thing about
it is
like walk me through the transition
you're a trump advocate you're actually
in his white house you're communicating
his message
and then a matter of months later
all of a sudden i mean i got a wake-up
call somebody calls me saying
turn on the tv listen to what mooch is
doing on trump you're not going to
believe this
and lo and behold you were going in a
different direction mooch what what
happened there
two years though so i i left the white
house july 31st 2017
on august 8 2019 i'm on the bill moore
show kevin
i am defending president trump uh
comments are coming under the economy i
defend them comments are coming in on
regulation i defend him
comments are coming in on judicial
appointments i'm defending him
and then bill turns to me and says well
what about these comments he made
about the squad and just for everybody
listening those are four
congresswomen that are two are
african-american ones hispanic american
one's a muslim american
uh their radical left in our country
and mr trump the president said go back
to the countries
that you originally came from and so
bill maher asked me what did i think of
that tweet i said i don't like that i
said they told my italian american
grandparents
a hundred years ago to go back to the
countries it really
it's a racist nativist trope quote
i really wish the president would not
say that
okay now we're at the after party i
don't know if you've done the show we
probably have we're having a soda pop
together
he turns to he says you know trump's not
going to like that he's going to tweet
at you tonight i said bill why would he
do that
i gave him and i raised him millions of
dollars
i was on his transition team i've been
an advocate for him in the media
he goes nah trump's a demigod you got to
go 13 for 10 for trump
and you were seven for eight for trump
tonight he's gonna hit you on twitter
i said okay let me tell you he's not
gonna do that i'll take the opposite
side of that
but if he does then i'm done with the
guy because then he really is a
demagogue
i'm trying to support him the next day
i'm at craig's a restaurant i have seen
you in you and i hang out in there
you and i like the same places beverly
hills hotel craig's
and i'm at craig's and i'm talking to
craig and boom
on my phone i'm getting blasted by the
president united states now let me tell
you your list or something you see this
piece of paper
your face goes as white as this piece of
paper anybody that tells you
they can take the heat from an incoming
presidential tweet when he's calling you
a low life or
an unstable nut job no you can't you get
very pale
your buddy jay seris is sitting at the
table with me
i said do you believe this and you could
ask jay to quiet
white like this i went into the bathroom
craig's i literally threw water on my
face
and i said this son of a [ __ ] i'm gonna
go and respond to it and i did
i hit him pretty hard because you know
i'm a pretty good troller i think so you
know i'm a new yorker we know how to
troll
so you got you got into a twitter fight
with the president united states i think
i called him fidel
adolf trump because i knew that the the
initials was f.a.t
so it was like the notorious f.a.t so i
had to get the fat shaming in there
with the fact that so much what do you
think the outcome of that what
how could that possibly be a good thing
when you're fighting
i mean any in anybody's career to be in
a fight with the president of the united
states the office of the united states
i mean first of all just that'd be a
great thing though i thought it was a
great thing because
because listen learning lessons for your
people okay
principles stand on your principles
don't back down if you think you're
right
you know morality if you've got a moral
center
and somebody's talking about somebody
with racist invective
it's okay to admit that you don't like
that and you think it's racist
you don't have to change your whole
personality or move
the moral goal posts in your life to
support the president united states
be honest about it call balls and
strikes so no i think it's a good thing
now he's hitting me
so i'm hitting him and then kevin you're
not going to believe this or maybe he
will believe he goes after my wife
is this guy nuts he goes after my wife
she is a suburban housewife on long
island he knows her and i were marital
problems
when i was working for him he starts
attacking my wife on twitter
i told his team that's it for me you're
not going after my wife
kevin take a look get closer to me do i
look like ted cruz to you
just take a look does this look like ted
cruz
no so you basically go after my wife
and so now the fight starts
i want to glean from this for all of our
listeners who are young millennials
looking for career advice
you're basically saying you have a moral
compass and you cannot
stray from it is that basically your
message 100 because let me tell you
something about your business
and my business you know the asset
management side of your business let me
emphasize it is about integrity the
market is going to go up the market's
going to go down
you're going to make a decision or at
least i certainly will on a bad
investment i may buy something at 10 it
goes to 5. but if i'm honest about it
and i'm open about it and i have
integrity
my clients are going to be with me
through thick and thin and so
what clients can see from a person so
wait a minute they got integrity they're
going to hold their ground they're going
to stand on their two feet
they're not going to be intimidated
that's somebody i want to go to war with
that's somebody
i want by my side helping me with my
situation in life and so it's been very
beneficial in my business
yes did some trump supporters leave
certainly they did and some did some
non-trump supporters
join my visit certainly they did but but
mooch let me let me ask you a question
that i i think
that everybody asked me about politics
you you ventured in there you explained
how you got there
i have learned as a television you know
person
and i've been told this multiple times
by various
network executives don't stray
into politics because half of your
audience
is the other side and and when you
do that you hurt our ability to grow
our programming to to get our message
out i mean obviously shark tanks about
entrepreneurship
and inspiration about building your own
business and it's very important to me
obviously
i've been doing it for 12 years but when
you go down the road of politics it
doesn't matter which side you go on
you're alie alienating half the the
population
and it's very costly in in in doing
and you went from one side to the other
side you basically did a full
round trip on this thing because you're
no longer an advocate for trump you were
at the beginning
not really so everything you said i'm
going to agree with a thousand percent
my mistake was i should have stayed as a
garden variety republican fundraiser
and no one would have mattered my
politics that's fine you're allowed to
give your money
to anybody you want and as michael
jordan said and perhaps your producers
say
you know republicans buy sneakers and
they watch tv shows and so do democrats
michael jordan always was hey you're a
democrat or republican he said oh
both sides by sneakers that is the right
thing to do in business so please if
you're listening
don't follow my path but my path
kevin is an accidental one and my path
is filled with the pitfall of ego the
trap door came down
on me when i went into politics it
opened and when i fell
in there i got stuck now i'm the michael
corleone
of politics okay i'm trying to get out
and they keep bringing me back in okay
and so what am i going to do i got to
have a position
and i have to have a message and my
message is anti-demagoguery
and my message is anti-people that are
trying to subvert our democracy i'm a
republican
a lifelong republican i'm a moderate
republican
when this is over i'd like to return to
my business and grow my business and
focus on
my life and my family but what i'm not
going to do is i'm not going to sit
there the country that i love
and we got a guy blowing racist dog
whistles no low-income housing in the
white suburbs
i'm like what are you talking about i
lived in an area that was surrounded by
low-income housing
those blacks and hispanics i lived with
grew up and created great businesses
businesses that you would be proud to
invest in on shark tank what is this guy
talking about
i don't like it okay so i spoke out
about it
i then figured out i was doing something
wrong i was going to white ethnics which
i happen to be i said don't don't vote
for trump it turns out they were going
to double vote for him
so i went into the african-american
community i said look who's this guy's
doing
and we increased their voter turnout and
we had a successful outcome
but by the way i'm very happy that the
senate
looks like it will be in the control of
the republicans yeah i mean before we
leave politics i have to get your take
on where we're at this has been an
extraordinary election week it's been
very very crazy
i mean they're still counting votes and
all of that stuff but
you know it's looking like the path for
a trump re-election is getting narrower
and narrower as
as it's getting tighter in these these
these battleground states
but but al also which stunned me and i'm
sort of in your camp too
there is no blue wave so so both parties
have learned
something radical about you know the the
the the positioning they took
i mean telling people that they're that
vote for trump whether you like them or
not
telling them that they're immoral
doesn't look like that worked out for
the democrats
and you know trump's positioning as
you've detailed doesn't look like it
captured enough of the
the urban voter and so what what what
take
what takes you are you you're taking
from this election what is your message
from let me give you
three things okay the trump voter is not
deplorable
okay and the trump voter is not a racist
i grew up with the trump voter i
understand the trump voter and the trump
voter
is a clarion call of a disaffection
from what is going on in the system the
trump voter is saying
this system is not working for me i am
poorer my family is poor
uh the family i grew up in kevin and
we've had this conversation at dinner
i grew up in an aspirational
working-class family
my father said go to school you're going
to live the american dream
that very same family has to deal with
26
decrease in living wages so now that
family's not in the middle class anymore
and so
in a generation we went from
working-class aspiration
to working-class desperation and those
people don't like the establishment they
don't like the media
it is a vote for themselves it's not
necessarily the second lesson
it's not necessarily a vote for mr trump
there's aspects of his personality they
don't like
but he doesn't represent the
establishment so therefore they're
voting
if they had a different messenger it was
less of a bully
less of the bellicosity of rhetoric that
person would have likely won by a
landslide
you can't lie about the science of the
covid you can't
disrupt the american economy you can't
denigrate
you know the prime minister of canada
and all the democratic leaders of the
west
at some point that's going to come back
to bite you so so the third lesson
is the radical left and the quote
unquote blue wave does not work for this
country
either and i would use an example of
corbinism you know who jeremy corbyn is
because you are a canadian
and jeremy corbyn was a hard
left-leaning guy that was running for
prime minister he got annihilated in the
united kingdom
and so you can't run a radical left
agenda in the united states this is a
group
of immigrants who are risk-taking
entrepreneurs
and so there was an interesting mixture
they split their tickets they voted for
joe biden
that was good for their soul and they
voted for their republican
representative in the congress or the
senate
that was good for their pocketbook and
so you're going to get hopefully a mixed
outcome
in the government which the market likes
kevin as you know because the market
likes that mixed government
right so so that's where we are right
now
my attitude is mr trump should leave
he lost the election the only reason why
they haven't sanctified the election yet
is they're preparing for a lawsuit
so all the secretaries of states of
those states that are up
in this dispute are triple checking
every vote
so when they have the lawsuit they can
put this guy lights out
but if this so but you you agree
you do agree mooch that he should fight
for his voters i mean trump should do
whatever he has to do to show that he
cares about the
60 plus million people that voted for
him i mean you've got to fight for your
team
and i understand when it's over it's
over but you have to fight you agree
with that don't you
i agree with that but you're in
overtime right now and when you
say quote unquote i may or may not
accept the peaceful transfer of power
and you are the leader of the free world
sitting atop of the
oldest republican demo democratic
experiment
in the world it is a very bad look
i have no problem with fighting for your
voters i have no problem with
being an advocate for people but you
lost okay and the irony is you've lost
by a bigger factor than you beat
secretary clinton if you look at the
vote totals and you look at the outcome
in the electoral college it's about 306
same as
he beat me he said that his 306
electoral victory was a landslide
so then definitionally joe biden has
beat him by a landslide and so therefore
be a man put your big boy pants on when
i got fired
i said hey my fault see you guys no
bitterness
trump is acting like a baby you've got
to cut it out i get it
i want to mooch i want to use some of
our time to for other matters let's
leave politics alone
you now there's a lot of people that are
interested in your television career
they want to understand because a lot of
people are interested in the media today
it's not just tv it's social media it's
reaching your message out there
you've been phenomenally successful
you've worked on multiple networks
you seem to have some engagement with
people that they like on television
let's help people that want to start
their career journey give some tips to
someone young
that would like to get into broadcast
television broadcast social media
broadcast
youtube all of these new channels what
advice let's say
i would say get long kevin o'leary
and slightly short anthony scaramucci
let me explain why because kevin o'leary
is doing it better than anthony
scaramucci how is he doing it better
stay out of politics okay number one
number two
okay uh do what kevin o'leary does
you are a boat lifter okay the reason
why all of these kids
like you is you're a boat lifter you're
a rising tide that's lifting boats
you look at those businesses you're like
yeah i want these people to succeed
i want them to reach the arc of their
personal and financial fulfillment
so be that person if you want to
talk about what makes you good on tv or
why you think i'm halfway decent well
let's just say
the generic attributes that someone
should think about a young person that's
just
coming out of college saying i want to
be that mooch guy on tv
how the hell do i get there how do i do
it
i mean what can i do and what what
attribute should i have well i would say
my career on tv is accidental i never
my first television appearance was when
i was 46 but if you really want to do
this then you got to practice
it's 10 000 hours of practice i in 2009
you'll enjoy this story i had president
bill clinton at my salt conference which
hopefully someday i can get you to and
uh
he said to me you know you're pretty
good on tv i see on cnbc who's your
media coach
and i said president clinton i i don't
have a media coach he goes oh that's a
mistake
doesn't tiger woods have a golf coach
and i said yes he does he says okay i'm
going to put you in touch with my media
coach
and so i did 15 hours of media training
with a guy named michael sheehan
may know michael he's down in dc and he
helped me help me think about where the
camera was he helped me think about
where my hands were helped me think
about
how i was going to gesticulate and talk
to people
and he said something to me that i will
never forget that i will share with
everybody on this podcast
if you're subjected to stage fright
i don't know shark tank probably has 15
or 20 million viewers so when you're
opening your mouth
15 or 20 million people are listening to
you or if you're giving a live
presentation you may have some anxiety
he told me something i will never forget
i'm going to share it with everybody
each one of those people kevin you could
have a one-on-one conversation with each
one of those people you'd be totally
comfortable you walked into their
living room and said hello i'm kevin i'm
anthony and you start talking
so you just imagine yourself doing that
and just experientially grow it to those
people because they're all
people that you could get along with in
a one-on-one conversation so therefore
dial right into the conversation that
you're in in the moment and relax
and the minute you do that the camera
picks up that you're doing that
and then the people watching you relax
if you get to the television and you're
like this
and you're and you're back up in here
like that and you start reading
from the page and they see that you're
uncomfortable then the viewer is losing
interest but if the viewer sees you
as relaxed as oh i'm getting kevin
o'leary in his original authentic form
on shark tank i'm getting mark cuban
the way mark cuba would be in his living
room if he was talking to me directly
that's how you create your television
success so what i like about that
message because i'm also going to
disclose this i
too have a media coach i go to him all
the time
and i just present myself and show them
all tape of me or maybe tape from last
week
and he's constantly pointing out
mistakes that i make but i i really like
this idea that you can constantly be
learning how to be better
on a medium than constantly changing in
the way it changes and and i think
coaching is a fantastic attribute i
agree with you on that
let's move on to another aspect that i
wanted to ask you about you're raising a
family you've got
you've got kids how do you coach them
about finances in life what do you tell
them about
building their own net worth and how to
go forward and not tripping
up in that aspect so many kids come out
of college
80 000 in debt and they go straight
downward from there
what advice do you give young kids in
terms of starting their careers and
taking care of themselves financially
okay so i was that kid i came out of
school
in 1989 with six figures plus in debt
between tufts and harvard
my parents didn't have the money to pay
for so i had to pay for
and here's what i would tell kids go buy
the richest
man in babylon by george clayson
it's a book about this big very thin
maybe 100 pages you can read it in two
hours
and it totally changed my life and it
totally changed the way i thought about
wealth and savings and what did the book
say to me when i read it in march 24
save a little each month pay yourself
each month you've said it drop the latte
and put it in your mutual fund and all
of a sudden it's a tiny acorn
that will eventually grow into an oak
tree and what the richest
man in babylon said which i thought was
so fascinating
is the value of compounding and so i've
heard you say this so i'm going to
repeat it but i'm going to footnote you
if you had a magic penny and that penny
was going to double
every day for 30 days would you rather
have that or
10 000 a day for 30 days and of course
kids can get tripped up they say well
ten thousand dollars a day is 300 grand
i'll take that versus the penny
but you know and i know the value of
compounding the pennies two cents
it's four cents it's eight cents by the
time you get to the 30th day it's 5.4
million dollars
and if we're in july kevin it's 10.8
million dollars
and the point being is that if you can
think like that as a young kid
and you can use all that time i was
paying
the debt off but then i was putting 200
into an account
paid the debt okay three hundred dollars
oh i got a little more money
i'm not gonna buy that bigger car or
that bigger house four hundred dollars
under my mutual fund
five hundred dollars on my mutual fund
all of a sudden i'm sitting on a
a asset and then that asset brings me
less anxiety because now i know i have a
cushion
to pay these bills that are coming in
every week and by the way i made a note
to myself always have goals like you
said
write down your goals i made a note to
myself the minute i pay off all my
school
debt i'm leaving goldman sachs to start
my first business
and that's what i did i was 32 years old
seven years at goldman
i left and built built my first company
i was stunned during the pandemic when
we started getting the ppv loans that so
many of the employees and the companies
i've invested and haven't saved anything
and i keep telling them
take 100 bucks a week and invest that in
something that's part of the market
because over time it'll compound
by the time you're 65 you'll have a
million and a half bucks in the bank
even if you just take 100 bucks a week
so i totally agree with you on that
a little bit about education what do you
tell
um young people today about investing in
college because let's say it's going to
cost them 60 grand
is it worth it i mean you've you
obviously went through a crazy path
the whole harvard thing and then the
cost of doing that
when you talk to somebody today that's
graduating from high school what advice
would you give them about
investing 60 000 80 000 in debt in
themselves
i i would give them the same advice that
i would give my children
and like you i'm an atypical person i'm
willing to be a disrupter i don't have
to be that status quo
tough harvard robot my oldest son
who you met tufts university stanford
business school
worked at google he's now building his
own company
that's his path he would he wanted that
graduate school education
my 21 year old son that was taking those
pictures of you and me that
does the 3d motion photography he's now
a videographer in la he's working with
machine gun kelly and travis barker
okay those are guys that your
millennials and your below millennials
are generation z people that watch you
know
he's their videographer he's got over 40
million views on videos that he's
produced
that's his dream he left college to do
that
so my message to people is you don't
have to be a college graduate today
to fulfill your dream the flip side
though is
if you think it's valuable to you invest
the money in the college and you may
even enjoy it my
my older son said to me you know what
dad i would enjoy the network
and if i can get into stanford business
school i'm going okay great and the good
news for him is i was able to pay for it
for him
but even if i wasn't that's a good
investment for him if that's what he
wants to do
so don't have a cookie cutter approach
you got to be a swiss army knife in life
find the tool that you think is best for
you to use and use that tool
i think you said one thing there that i
want to pick up on that really mattered
to me and i've learned through the long
journey of it
i don't remember anything i learned in
college but i still have all the
contacts i met right through my mba
and business degree and i think that's
the message that i'm hearing
that is most important if you're going
if you're going to invest that time
and obviously going to harvard as the el
supremo but those contacts ended up
being very important for you later in
life when you were fundraising when
you're in the white house for that brief
sin
in raising your hedge fund all that
stuff those people
i assume you're telling everybody that
was the investment
not the stuff you sat through and
learned about variable cost analysis
because you remember
i also got some education though you
know a little bit of history you're able
to apply context to modern life
he got a degree in economics so i
understand statistics which helped me in
money management i
i did learn some things but you're
making a big point which i can't
overemphasize
is the network is invaluable but you
know what
you may know and you know i'm talking to
individuals out there that are listening
to kevin i speak
you may know that the network that
you're going to
in college may not be as significant as
a network that you may be able to create
in the music industry
or the network you could create in tv or
that you know you have to weigh it it's
a cost benefit analysis but
here's the one last thing you can
bounce you don't want to be a piece of
bone china when you have bad stuff
happening to you okay let's talk about
something bad happen you haven't put
something a bad day
think of me getting fired from the white
house and getting lit up on late night
comedy and going through the shawshank
sewer fight for a year
okay so and guess what you can bounce
you can be resilient
you can shake it off you can use your
sense of humor
and so if you're having a setback in
life don't let it
affect the overall existential
power of your positivity or the aura
that you're presenting to the rest of
the world
when stephen colbert invited me on his
show two weeks after i got fired
he said hey mooch did you think you were
going to last a long time in the white
house
stephen i said i thought i was going to
last longer than a carton of milk in the
refrigerator and he was getting blown
out before the milk spoiled
and the point is you know he looked at
me he said all right this guy gets it he
rolled into the pain
of what happened to him i don't pretend
it didn't happen
i don't pretend that i did the right
thing and other people did the wrong
thing i don't play the victim
say hey i got nailed i did something
really stupid
so that may happen to you in your
entrepreneurship i know
without knowing this that you've had a
few setbacks you've had to of
because you've created this unbelievable
arc of success in your life
and to do that you've had to take some
risk and i'm sure you stepped on a few
landmines over the course of your career
and it was how you adjusted and adapted
that has made you kevin o'leary and mr
wonderful i
i agree with you am i wrong about that
no you're not and i i love that message
it's very important you have to deal
with adversity and you have to move on
and learn from it
i want to touch on one last thing
because you've been great today
besides all this focus on work and
creating
wealth and you know driving business
what do you do to have
fun and how important is that to you to
have a little fun once in a while
because we're not going to be on this
earth forever
talk to me about that well i think you
know because you and i have had more
than one dinner together with our pals
you and i are both fun-loving guys so
the adage work harding play hard
is in the o'leary scaramucci gene boy i
think we both know that
but what i would tell people is there's
a time and place for everything and you
should be able to enjoy yourself but if
you pick a good job
and you pick a job that you love you're
going to love the job you know i went to
go see david rubenstein you know david
yeah he's up in nantucket
his front door beautiful house on the
bluff
you walk up to the front door there's a
sign on the door it says i'd rather be
working
and it's his wry sense of humor to let
you know he's got this beautiful house
on the bluff and ocean
and everything but he likes working and
he's chosen that for his life you know
and so the point i'm making
is it's okay don't judge yourself
and don't you don't have to be the guy
in esquire magazine that has everything
but you have to be the guy or the woman
that is doing what you want to do
with life and the portfolio of time that
you have so for me
i'm a big reader you can see these books
back here room raider doesn't like
them because they're on a horizontal you
see them back there yeah
but i'm i'm a big reader um i'm a
uh i i love sports and athletics
uh you know i owned a piece of the mets
it just got sold to my friend steve
cohen
uh but i love i love i'm a sports
enthusiast
i do love politics i have to confess
that that's something that bit me
and i love that policy discussion and i
love learning about it
and i love hanging out with my kids you
know that's me everyone else
my brother my brother kevin you haven't
met him but my brother's a scratch
golfer this guy plays golf
nine times a week i don't even i don't
know how he does it you know but
everybody should do whatever it is they
like
doing and you and you set it up like a
pizza pie this pup piece is for saving
this is for work that piece over there
is for play
and you don't want to do too much of any
one thing because that's what makes it
so interesting
well thank you so much and i can't wait
mooch till we're back doing what we used
to do having those great dinners in l.a
or new york
i mean that i miss more than anything
this pandemic is getting on my nerves i
have to admit
by also what i miss the most i have to
confess this and everybody the reason
why people tune in to you
you got the best sense of humor man you
know how to laser focus in on the like
the cheeky thing that's going on right
in the moment
and i miss hanging out with you i hope
you guys soon well listen thank you so
much for your time today it's been
fantastic
and i i just you know i look forward to
that this too will pass we'll be out of
this pandemic one day and i will
see you soon take care my friend thank
you god bless